[音楽]
voodoo
[拍手]
[音楽]
皆さんは将来自動運転車が世の中に普及すると思いますか
私はこの質問が数年後には馬鹿らしくなるぐらいに少しでも早く
自動運転車を当たり前のものとしてして広めていきたいと考え取り組んでいます
これまで
自動運転化の歴史は50年以上も続いてきました
やっとここ数年にあって
コンピューターの性能や
画像処理の手法も進化し
いよいよ実用化やという段階にきています
これはわれわれが実験を行っている自動運転のバスです
国内の公道で初めてそして無人の状態で
自動運転ますの実験を行いました
このように
現在
実証実験を進めている状況ですが
自動運転を実用化するなんてに30年後じゃないかとか
絶対に無理だとかいう厳しい声をいただくこともあります
しかし世の中で
自動運転を求める声はとても大きいんです
私は移動の課題を下げるために各地の現場を見て回りました
docomo 運転手が不足しており特に田舎に住む高齢者の方が移動手段がなく困っ
ていました
なんと現場では地方のバス会社の8割以上が赤字なんです
今はなんとか実際が補助金を負担してバスを走らせていますが敗戦は免れない状況に
なってきています
そんななか高齢者が無理をして運転し事故を起こしてしまう
そういった状況を目にした時になんとかしてこの負の連鎖を断ち切らなくてはいけない
そう強く思いました
こういった現場で実際に課題を目にしたときの気持ちが私が今大きな課題に取り組む時
の原動力にそして情熱になっています
ここで私の原点について少しお話したいと思います
私は小さい頃からものづくりが好きでいろいろな物を作っていました
もちろん車も大好きでした
小学校の光にはこういった
コースター型の乗り物によって寝てるあ大学校についていたらいいのにと言った
想像していました
今思い返してみると自動運転車の発想に近いですよね
大学時代には
インターネットの魅力にとりつかれひたすらパソコンばかりいじっていました
世界中の情報を瞬時にリアルタイムで手に入れることができる
そんなインターネットの力を利用すれば
テコの原理のように小さな力で大きな課題を解決することができるのではないか
そんなことを考えていました
そして今
世の中は
身の回りのあらゆるモノがインターネットにつながる iot 化が進んでいます
自動車は iot の代表例です
そんな時代の転換期において自分が夢中になったインターネットと大好きな車をつなぐ
ことができる
ど真ん中のポジションにいることができてほんとうに面白いと感じています
多くの人が自動運転車と聞いて思い浮かべるのはどこでも行ける
自動運転車ではないでしょうか
しかしどこでも行ける自動運転車を
すぐに実用化するのは難しいです
なぜならすべての道の高精度な地図を持ち
連覇や gps が必ず入ることを確認し
通信できる信号機を設置したり
そういった走りにくい眼鏡でも走ることができる性能が必要になってくるからです
そこで我々は決まったルートを走る自動運転のバスを公共交通として使うことでそれら
の課題をクリアし
少しでも早く行動で実用化ができると考えています
ということで冒頭にお見せしたような自動運転のバスに注力しているんです
また自動運転というと走る曲がる止まるといった
自動運転の制御技術に注目が集まりますが
実用化するために重要なのは持続可能なサービスとして提供することなんです
持続可能なサービスとあ
しっかりと採算がない等
ユーザーにとっても便利なダイヤが組まれそして人間的な温かみが感じられるサービス
です
私は車を売るのではなく移動体験を提供したい
そう考えています
車両というのは自動運転に必要な1つの要素でしかありません
バスの自動運転化を考えたときに今の運転さんが行っている仕事は運転以外にも数多く
あることが分かりました
バス停での料理するお客さんを確認したり
現金の両替や社内のトラブルに対応したり
それから乗客の質問に答えてい
それらを自動化する必要もあるんです
そして最も重要な安全安心を届けるために
バスの車内を見守る仕組みをつくりました
このように ai を使って
走行中の車内を移動する人を自動で検知し運転を制御します
これによって
バスの車内で非常に多い転倒事故を防ぐことができるんです
こうして作ったサービスはしっかりと使い勝手の検証を考えを行います
誰でも使えるように昨年には
自治体あー地域と連携して
自動運転を想定したバスを
スマートフォンから予約する市民にトライしました
伊佐に使っていただいたのはバスが廃線となった地域に住んでいる
65歳以上の方々です
こういった高齢者や
it に疎い人はなかなかスマートフォンを使って予約するのは難しいんじゃないかと
思いがちですが本当に移動に困っている方々は何とか頑張ってスマートフォンを使って
誘惑してくれるんです
とっても良い方ですよね
こういったリアルなユーザーの協力も得て使い勝手を少しずつ改善し
実用化へ進めています
ということで今まで紹介した自動運転の実用化を早めるポイントを整理すると一つ目が
決まったルートを走る自動運転のバスであることをそして2つ目がしっかりと採算が
ない+持続可能なサービスとして提供することそして3つ目が地域や利用者に密着した
使いやすいサービスに仕上げていくとこれらの3つです
これから何年か先
自動運転の制御技術はいずれ頭打ちになることが予想されます
そしてその先はサービスが競われるようになるんです
似たような例を紹介すると携帯電話と同じです
皆さんは携帯電話会社を選ぶ時に
通信率の高さで選びますか
それよりも
サービス内容や料金プラン機種などで選びますよね
私は自動運転車にも
携帯型と同じようにお客さんにサービスを届ける存在が不可欠だと考えています
これまで携帯電話が世の中に普及するためには
携帯電話キャリアが大事な役割を果たしてきました
各種サービス料金プランなどを取りそろえてユーザーに提供する
時には格安の端末を用意したり
高齢者にも分かりやすく説明したりそうすることで利用者を増やし
やがて文化として平成されるようになったんです
それと同じように将来的には自動運転キャリアが
さまざまなメーカーの自動運転車を取り揃えてユーザーに便利な形で提供する
そのような姿になっていくんと私は考えています
そして
世の中に自動運転車が普及するとどうなるのか
世の中に普及した自動運転車は
iot として一つの
インターネットの一つのアウトプット
駆動装置として現実世界を直接操作することが可能になります
自動運転車によって
現実世界にインターネットが染み出してくると私は表現しているのですがちょっと抽象
的で分かりづらいかもしれません
どういうことか
これまで
インターネットで紹介されたお店や
案内された場所に実際に行く判断をして行動するのは人間でした
しかし自動運転車が普及した未来では
インターネットの判断がそのまま車両に伝わり
極端に言うと人が気づかないうちに目的地まで移動が完了してしまうということです
別の例え方をするとこれまで頭脳だけだったインターネットに
手足がくっついたようなそんな状態です
そうなるとインターネットの
可能性
がもっともっと広がる面白い世界になるはずです
ぜひここは皆さんも一緒に考えていただきたい
こちらの写真をご覧下さい
行動ではないですが
東京電力の福島第一原発の中で働いている作業員の方々の移動手段として
自動運転バスを実用化さスター例です
私も実際に現場に入りましたが
原発の敷地内では1日廃炉に向けて6000人が働き
道路では歩く人やばす大型トラックなどが行き交う一つの町のような感じになってい
ます
そこでは将来の報道での実用化に向けた様々な経験値が積まれてきているんです
このように
私が子供のころに描いていた
妄想が少しずつ現実になりつつあります
さらにもうちょっと未来を描いてみましょう
車は所有からし和え
車の所有は一つの趣味となります
高齢者でも誰でも
移動したいときに魔法の絨毯のように
自動運転車を自在に呼び寄せることができる
寝たり
読書をしたり好きなことをしている間に目的地までついているといったことも可能に
なるでしょう
インターネット上の頭脳が
移動したい人と車両のバランスを調整し最小限の台数デー
人と物の移動支えている
人気のあるお店には自動運転車がどんどん人を集めてくる
しかもお店が
運賃を負担してくれて0円になることもある
夢が広がりますよね
でも私はこの夢を夢のままで終わらせるつもりはありません
本気で実現できると信じ切っています
自分が世界を変えるんだ
自分が世界の最前線なんだと
客観的に見たら違うかもしれませんがそんなのは関係ありません
自分が信じ切れているかどうかです
自動運転車の普及により移動に困っている人をゼロにしたい
そのためには
インターネットのごとく会社や国を超えて連携し力を合わせて必死で頑張るのみです
すでに
自動運転の実用化へのステップは皆さんのを持っている以上のスピードで回り始めて
いるんです
近い将来皆さんの目の前を自動運転車が通り過ぎたとき
私が最初にした質問を思い出してください
皆さんは将来自動運転車が世の中に普及すると思いますか
[拍手]
[音楽]